the French ambassador to Niger with
freed French hostages that were held
captive in this hell before being
released last March now it is the one
heading home he and other French
diplomats are back in Paris after
spending 33 days locked inside the
French Embassy in food rations French
president Macon has been accusing
niger's juntav holding his Ambassador
and staff hostage
since August protests flared outside the
compound demonstrators calling on the
French ambassador to leave a request
made by niger's Junta but the French
refused to recognize the legitimacy of
the coup and would not cooperate until
now
we are winning the game against France
and near colonialism so the departure of
Ambassador ite is a victory
they don't want just the Ambassador gone
Outside The Barracks housing French
troops they chant get out anger at their
presence is spreading on Sunday
president Macau announcing the
withdrawal of French troops before the
end of the year not soon enough for the
Junta and its supporters the French
military have been stationed in the
country since Independence niger's Junta
want them to leave as soon as possible
it's been too long since France brought
its Army here to Niger but they haven't
been able to eradicate terrorism so they
have ulterior motives French troops have
been used to secure the uranium
extracting activities of the French
company uranu who owns the rights to all
of the country's Minds the yellow cake
as it's known is exported to Europe's
nuclear power plant uranium from a poor
African nation being used to power a
rich European one the French have turned
into a nuclear superpower from people
who remain poor and without access to
electricity this is the cause of
enormous frustration and anger for the
people of Niger even if many are against
the coup the main issue is to get rid of
the colonizers that continue to exploit
our resources without us benefiting from
it despite being a leading exporter of
the precious metal Niger remains one of
the poorest countries in the world the
demonstrators say the country was taken
hostage by the interest of the former
colonial power the Junta promising to
set Niger free
Nicholas Hawk Al Jazeera
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera